[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal à d'actualité
d'information locale et voici les titres
de ce 19 octobre c'est l'événement
sportif de cet automne le championnat
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste c'est au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
que se déroule jusqu'à dimanche la
compétition elle les français entendent
se reprendre après des olympiades raté à
la demande de l'état le département des
yvelines expérimentera en novembre
prochain l'instruction des cartes
nationales d'identité sur les stations
biométriques les explications au cours
de cette édition
retour sur le festival du théâtre
amateur de saint-cyr-l'ecole cinq pièces
en représentation avec un objectif vous
faire mourir de rire c'est donc le début
des vacances de la toussaint elles vont
s'étaler sur deux semaines avec un
retour sur le chemin de l'école le jeudi
3 novembre certains parents rencontrent
des difficultés avec ses dates pour
s'organiser en cause le début des congés
en plein milieu de semaine
plusieurs solutions sont envisagées
prendre des jours demandé aux grands
parents de garder les enfants ou encore
les centres de loisirs écouter ces
quelques réactions à la sortie des
courses me dit ma femme travaille en
équipe nationale on n'a pas eu trop de
soucis car les vacances scolaires comme
les enfants que par contre moi je
travaille je continue à travailler ça ne
pose pas de problème pour nous pour
garder les enfants tout ça va presque
c'est pas assez pas l'idéal pour les
autres parents justement pour les
vacances et tout ça s'est passé parce
que c'est lui qui a voulu garder le
petit oui parce que sa mère nous a
demandés sur l'été là et que
si hockey donc on nous comme on n'a pas
trouvé de partir on va le garder toutes
les trois jours là et après ces paroles
qui vont le garder ce qui se tourne à
cause mais si
si on avait braqué la barre est au
centre propos recueillis par nicolas
landry après les championnats du monde
en 2015 le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueille à
partir d'aujourd'hui les championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste l'équipe
de france a décidé de miser sur une
nouvelle génération après le fiasco des
jo cet été sur place michael et demi
d'euros et patrick jacques dehais
dixmude la cérémonie d'ouverture vient
tout juste de se terminer
effectivement wilfried la cérémonie
d'ouverture vient de se terminer ici au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
la duré une vingtaine de minutes une
trentaine d'enfants de saint quentin en
yvelines a défilé sur la piste avec des
drapeaux des pays présents ici pour les
championnats d'europe il a également eu
un discours des officiels avec notamment
michel logis le président de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au niveau de
l'ambiance on attend entre 2000 et 2500
personnes ici au vélodrome en semaine et
puis le 3500 le week-end autant dire que
ça ne fera pas le plein mais le
vélodrome devrait être bien garni tout
de même sur la piste 28 nations et plus
de 270 coureurs sont présents ici au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on a pu notamment voir les cyclistes
belges les cyclistes espagnols et la
grande bretagne et bien sûr les pays bas
pour la france on est en opération
reconquête exit françois permis grégory
baugé et michael d'almeida tous les
trois ont été exclus par la fédération
suite à leur comportement à rio l'été
dernier par contre les nouvelles têtes
d'affiché seront quand à la far qui
habite saint quentin en yvelines et qui
a 25 ans il y aura également l'endurance
benjamin thomas 21 ans au niveau des
objectifs six médailles d'or sont
espérés par l'équipe de france merci
michael et nous suivrons régulièrement
cette actualité des championnats sur
piste championnats d'europe ce sera
notamment à la thématique du prochain si
on parlait sport à l'antenne dès ce
jeudi 19h30 émission également avoir à
la demande sur notre site internet en
marge de l'aspect sportif nous avons
aussi voulu savoir ce que les commerces
de saint quentin en yvelines pouvait
attendre en termes de retombées
économiques
reportage auprès des hôtels et des
restaurants préparé par haussmann
vendeurs des patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est le jour j pour les championnats
d'europe qui débutent aujourd'hui tous
les athlètes se sont préparés pour
l'événement mais pas seulement les
commerces 50 noms du aussi préparer
l'arrivée des visiteurs et des athlètes
comme à l'hôtel ibis situé juste à côté
du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui a dû
adapter ses repas au niveau de la
restauration en tout cas des menus
adaptés à une clientèle sportive sur le
restaurant bicycle heures ce qui est
située dans le même bâtiment que de tel
donc des repas sportif de deux pattes
blanc play de dinde en tout cas tous
pourront garantir les meilleurs niveaux
de performance pendant cette compétition
du 19 jusqu'au 23 octobre l'hôtel est
complet ce qui représente environ 1200
chambres mais il n'ya pas que les hôtels
qui attendent l'arrivée des sportifs les
restaurants aussi comme le bistrot du
théâtre à montigny le bretonneux qui est
prêt à les accueillir nous on est un
établissement qui fonctionne
relativement complet donc on est on a
toujours une une rue de deux ou trois
jours d'avant son stock et là évidemment
on a renforcé sur les produits notamment
les pâtes les choses comme ça qui les
sportifs prennent beaucoup quoi durant
les championnats d'europe le bistrot du
théâtre envisage une augmentation de son
chiffre d'affaires de 15% les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste se déroule du 19 au 23 octobre
dès le 8 novembre les démarches pour
demander une carte d'identité vont être
simplifiées pour les yvelinois les
habitants pourront faire leurs prêts
demande en ligne sur internet plus
besoin de se rendre exclusivement auprès
de la mairie de sa ville et de remplir
le formulaire papier la demande de la
carte d'identité et maintenant effectuer
selon les mêmes modalités que le
passeport après votre pré demande il
faut vous rendre pour un rendez vous
dans l'une des 34 mairies équipées du
dispositif de prise d'empreintes et
donner les pièces justificatives
le département des yvelines est le
premier à expérimenter ces mesures on
écoute julien charle c'est le secrétaire
général de la préfecture des yvelines au
micro de camille lambert pour l'usager
ce sera donc à la fois plus simple plus
sécurisé aussi parce que ça permettra
pour nous de lutter plus efficacement
contre la fraude et puis bien sûr plus
rapide pour les services des mairies
comme pour les services de la préfecture
c'est un processus plus simple parce
qu'il y aura une seule manière
d'instruire les demandes ce que ce soit
la carte d'identité que ce soit les
passeports ça se fera d'une seule et
même façon nous allons donc lancer la
procédure sur les cartes d'identité et
les passeports mais nous allons aussi
travailler sur les permis de conduire
travailler sur les cartes grises de
façon que la fin de l'année 2017 et bien
l'ensemble de ces titres soient délivrés
de façon plus rapide plus simple et plus
fiables les chiffres de la sécurité
routière sont connus ils ne sont pas
bons dans le département des yvelines la
route a fait 36 morts depuis le début de
l'année contre 33 pour les neuf premiers
mois de 2000 15 les deux roues motards
cyclistes et piétons représentent plus
de deux tiers des victimes les
opérations de prévention mais aussi de
répression vont donc se multiplier dans
les prochaines semaines l'actualité
politique à présent et ce départ de le
groupe majoritaire du conseil
départemental des yvelines de philippe
brillault celui qui est également maire
les républicains du chéné conteste le
rapprochement engagé avec les hauts de
seine pour le président du département
pierre bédier il est légitime d'avoir
des divergences et de les exprimer
philippe brillault va donc conserver ses
différentes délégations philippe
brillault qui sera présent sur ce
plateau pour le 7-8 les invités sur
notre antenne donc demain jeudi à partir
de 18h30
partie soir l'académie des sciences
morales des arts et des lettres qui
était à versailles faisait sa rentrée
solennelle et pour cette première
conférence l'académie recevait un ancien
ministre ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères hubert védrine l'ex
conseiller de françois mitterrand a
parlé à de son dernier ouvrage le monde
au défi et il a développé également son
idée de géo écologie le reportage de
nicolas kirillovitch
hubert védrine en est convaincu les
problématiques environnementales et
écologiques vont bouleverser les
relations internationales face à un
monde divisé et des enjeux qui diffèrent
selon les pays la sauvegarde de la terre
pourrait devenir la cause commune de
toutes les nations un propos que
l'ancien ministre du gouvernement de
lionel jospin a expliqué devant un
public est attentif à versailles par les
jeunes des pays qui ne joueraient pas le
jeu
ap avoir chiné les engagements
concernant le climat à l'éco diversité
la réduction des nuisances ou la
protection des espèces animales
protégées loyer et qui ne joueraient pas
le jeu après seront désignés montré du
doigt récemment la procureur de la cour
pénale internationale a annoncé qu'elle
allait se saisir elle même des crimes
écologiques donc je crois qu'une
évolution
et que progressivement ça va influencer
la géopolitique qui ont une double
notion de compétitivité écologique une
champ de crime écologique contre
l'humanité etc etc et pour établir un
lien entre écologie et géopolitique
hubert védrine propose notamment la mise
en place d'un pib écologique et une
demande d'appel je pense que les
économistes devraient essayer de
calculer en matière de chasse et que
tout simplement les flux que mesure le
pib déjà mais la question des stocks
aujourd'hui on rase une forêt ça n'a pas
de c pas pris en compte dans un calcul
économique d'investissement classiques
200 personnes environ étaient présentes
pour cette conférence organisée par
l'académie des sciences morales des arts
et des lettres de versailles un public
convaincu globalement par les idées
défendues par l'ex ministre la grande
idée c'est qu'il faudra arriver à un
consensus mondial mais sur quelles bases
l'établir sur l'écologie si sa thèse
c'est une très belle idée et encore du
chemin à faire son innovation du pib
écologique me paraît très intéressant
donc il faut poursuivre mais ça sera un
travail comme il a dit de très longue
haleine à plus court terme l'accord de
paris sur le climat devrait entrer en
vigueur début novembre
un mode de culture à présent le week end
dernier avait lieu à saint cyr l'école
le festival mort de rire au programme de
cette manifestation réservée au théâtre
amateur cinq pièces très différentes
pour satisfaire tous les publics parmi
elles une oeuvre originale mettant en
scène les intrépides pensionnaires d'une
maison de retraite anne-laure l'anguille
sur des images de patrick jacques de
dixmude
à l'abri de peupliers trois grands pères
y changent leurs souvenirs sur la
terrasse de leur maison de retraite
jusqu'au moment où va naître leur désir
d'évasion le vent des peupliers pièce de
l'auteur contemporain gérard sibleyras
étaient au programme du festival mort de
rire c'est une troupe amateur baptisé
hauteur de vue qui s'est donné le défi
de la jouer nous avons été séduits par
ces trois personnages trois petits vieux
dans un hospice dans des temps où on n'a
plus affaire à un annuaire qu'autre
chose là ils sont pleins de vie encore
est totalement séduisant et inénarrable
encadré par un metteur en scène
professionnel les comédiens ont laissé
libre cours à leurs interprétations un
jeu subtile rythmée par les rires du
public rien à voir avec le thème de
bouvard s'éteint c'est un théâtre
intimiste où les rires sont des rires
très peu de rire au premier degré on n'a
plus
un retour du rire face à des situations
ou à des phrases clé un choc
moi j'ai eu un étourdissement
[Musique]
créée en 2003 la pièce a connu un vif
succès en la choisissant le festival
mort de rire mais talonneur le théâtre
contemporain ça change un petit peu et
pour le coup ce festival 2016 est plutôt
varié dans la programmation donc après
une pièce classique hier soir un
vaudeville plus tard dans l'après midi
voilà je me disais qu'ils avaient
complètement leur place pour ce festival
cette pièce nous invite à porter un
autre regard sur la vieillesse fait de
tendresse et d'humour
chassables tranché ça nous rappellera de
bons souvenirs
et pour l'actualité culturelle sur saint
quentin en yvelines et la région vous
avez rendez vous avec mélanie poquet
pour le 7-8 culture chaque mercredi
19h15 pour la première diffusion je vous
retrouve demain pour un nouveau journal
[Musique]